hmm ok started a five-minute game and it
took a while to actually move the phone
all right so let's see what what's going
on here I think I play the Kings Indian
for a change ok so maybe the other back
variation yeah yeah black has some some
options here like when I played the
Kings Indian more often ok I played H
sticks but this some push-up h4 is a bit
unusual there should be three years the
normally played move here as some with
the bishop unknown on h4 this sound
banco gambit of approach gains in
strength simply because the bishop bone
doesn't have this Bishop d to move yeah
and this is some f3 is really strange
Howard how does he intend to develop his
King side now maybe he tries to I don't
know how it just it just looks somewhat
strange I must admit alright so how do I
continue here think you've got more than
one decent possibility
now it BTW 70 my plane i th 3r chesa not
what i want really it's not a huge
problem but it's not welcome i could
also play six trying to completely rip
open the position okay I try that it
goes night age three now I can just take
this at least speeds up my development
and he still cannot develop ask inside
this is really what I'm I want to
achieve here that he cannot get out his
pieces quickly on the King side I don't
care about material him quit d6 I think
I can already take on e4 f take see
Bishop c3b see Queen takes you three and
the rook is gone yeah okay wants to grab
more material so should I recapture or
do I have a better move 96 Sun comes to
mind I want I want this not only for
this looks much more attractive than
taking on a six
principal means that we may be to lose
the light Knight e5 for instance okay so
he decides to actually allow me to to
demolish a pawn structure here yeah
maybe he nearly needed to it's possible
okay do I have something better than
taking on age 3 which isn't isn't bad of
course don't think so can let's grab
this and what happens now just not to
deform now of course I sect some
material here it's not this nice
position didn't come for free I have how
many points down two points yeah
yeah my compensation is the other
excellent knight on d4 and possible
chances against this king also this
whole King side is Sir just shaky so on
what now something like rook the age
threatening would be to this smooth okay
let's speed up here ideal would be rugby
to Queen B to quincy 323 92 stuff like
this and the other idea also in general
could be too yeah simply move the night
maybe to age five and then try to get
Bishop b5 9f for stuff like this using
the F foursquare also okay just move the
bishop but what does he play on look
beep for who okay I'm in them and the
kind of self pen after this move of
course
you
yes to this still looks like like a move
yeah now i can take here takes you three
but i'm not sure this might be might be
not not as great as it looks okay not
much alternative I guess at the moment
the a porn is of course the the possible
problems other than that I'm radium but
the ape on a pond really am could could
could be Hector could be more than
dangerous this night controls be one and
d1 and its really yeah the star Pisa
without this night thats this whole
concept would be really rubbish okay
your text is six ok ok ok I need to get
rid of this pawn this is really a number
one priority here first this move kept
keeping our c5 protected and then I can
take it next move maybe also Bishop to
deform
also discoveries yeah I've got
discoveries with the night time morning
yeah first want to ensure that this
Bishop really gets to to deform locky
six and then take take on a six yeah
this looks nice so if i take a six now
Izzy seven dangerous I don't think so
yeah well this night is Sir Wow
fantastic piece really so um yeah take
take a phone now yeah let's let's grab
this keep it simple cha cha okay 93 to
f5 would be would be really nice now
naw 93-yard missed this right so I play
this a purely technical style here i
also have a jeep on white forfeits on
time yeah not sure i think it was wasn't
it interesting interesting game and this
is one of the strongest nights i really
saw for a long time covering all those
squares just great I'd like to check
quickly with the computer if he gives
something for wide funny you know what
the computer wants to play a rook a 2d
one but a 2d one just returning the the
exchange and leaving me with an extra
piece but he gives blacks an advantage
so okay this combination was good after
all the a porn is not dangerous because
of this monster night great yeah
sometimes do you really like your games
alright thanks for watching